I want to explain this a little bit more
detail. So, let's do this. If you look at
the timeline for a particular process of Pj, it
might look like this. That Ti was running here,
got de-scheduled, and then there were a couple of
other threads that ran on, on Pj, Tx and
Ty. So now if I want to think about
the affinity for Ti with respect to this processor Pj.
That affinity, if we're going to schedule Ti
now on Pj, the affinity number that I
want to compute for this guy is two,
indi-, indicating the number of intervening threads that ran
on Pj between the last time Ti ran on it, and if I schedule Ti now
at this point of time. And so clearly,
this number that I'm talking about, the affinity number,
the smaller the number the higher the affinity.
So when we say the affinity number is two,
it means there are two intervening threads that
ran on Pj between the time Ti got dibs
on Pj now at this point of time and at this point of time. 'Kay that's the
idea behind this affinity index. So what we want
to do is in a minimum intervening scheduling policy,
you want to keep this information about the affinity
for Ti to run on every processor. If I have
a multiprocessor with 16 processors, then there is an affinity
index associated with every one of those processors for Ti.
It might be that on processor one Ti has
an affinity index of two, on processor two it has
an affinity index of four and so on and so
forth. And what we want to do is when it
comes time to scheduling Ti, I want to pick a processor on which the affinity
index is the minimum. So the minimum affinity
index indicates that there is the minimum number
of intervening threads on this particular processor.
That's the processor on which I want to
run Ti. That is amplifying the chance that
Ti is going to find its memory contents,
the working set in the caches. That's
the idea behind minimum intervening scheduling policy.